today just happens to be Monday today
we're going to be picking our holiday
party winner for each other
what is your holiday party we're vibes I
really want to be like that rich bougie
auntie that like she has like a nice
tailored look like sophistication but
still class I'm open the colors I also
really like my boobs to be shown
I am very intellect with colorful
Blazers with a black turtleneck yes I
either want to be like regal it's like
very classic holiday look or I want
something completely different that's
like street style it turns out we only
have $100 each we have two sites we're
shopping right if so sign Amazon what is
anything that looks som that you
definitely don't want I do not want
heels because like they're a lot of like
colorful pants and I just don't want my
pants to be louder than the blazer how
much work in the dress
lots of easy choices first right now
we're on ASOS this looks like a condom
slip over someone's ba I'm not gonna
wear condom dress I mean it's hot no no
practice safe sex
really you don't think so I don't
dislike it
oh okay never mind the whole thing it's
very me goes ask it okay this is a
budget I like I love this video
that's hot that is really hot and we
could get like so we currently have four
right now that we have this inside but
we remember she's going for regal but
sexy I feel like currently this one
right here says that I agree cuz I want
something that'll draw attention but we
don't need a lot right choice we got you
it this is cute this is a great look
with her black heels we'll look yes it
will look at Tisha's it's 100% we're
picking
anything we want for Ryan he's gonna be
out of it it's gonna be over $100 yes
men are so fine I know I'm the obviously
I'm not even looking at the clothes I
went in to put like a paper bag or
something these faces are the worst part
of this if we do these the top has to be
great what's with the whole time looking
at just pants no board this one but then
I was thinking if we didn't go that
route we could get these two and make
him just wear black pants I also like
push the envelope you don't think this
is pushing it to me with this I think
he'll worry about again I think it'll
make him nervous at first what I think
the word again well then I think we
should get it do it it'll make me
nervous what is it like is it like is it
just what what about this clothing will
make me nervous is my question
you guys will match that's fun in color
and in texture that's all I'm saying Oh
a 98 25 Wow okay so we're looking up
inspo for jazz out there oh I like these
drop it in okay I'm gonna favorite
that's the thing is also finding things
that jazz doesn't already have
I think jasmine wouldn't buy this or get
this and I think she'd wear it twice yes
it's just overwhelming when you trying
to shop like a good look for your friend
what would you ideally see underneath it
can be colorful like she's like living
color I like it I love it let's do it
are you sure yeah when I think she's
gonna love it
that is ordered
so much stir yeah it is stressful I know
we gotta agree awful for you jazz I know
we got something new for you okay I'm
excited to share this and I think we'll
be cohesive it I'm excited
squat squat alas it's been a week and we
don't remember what we bought each other
we don't remember I'm today I don't
remember what you got it Ryan I know
what we got choice I remember what I got
oh my god you know I did am I just gonna
be naked well I thought I had a big
package but you know what they things
come in small packages oh I'm gonna see
what you hope got yeah I can't wait go
check okay
all right Wow I love God yeah how do you
feel I feel it do you like it I love
this I love the fit I love everything I
think I'm a little tight around the neck
it's hard to bend easily choke myself
you twerk twerk wait it's like a big
fuzzy thing this is a rope this is hot
oh my god I feel like that excitement
comes from a place of not trusting us
those who talk slowly
get hit ok ready ready come out to the
world Sonny Boy hi love I wish I would
have worn like a black belt cuz I love
this lace top oh my god this feels like
a road so what we wanted to do here was
um play with textures and so we had the
little texture here mixed with this
texture here I love I love that love
this is like such a like fun like Holly
look where I'm like oh I'm cozy and cute
yeah it's casual and hot at the same
time wait what these sounds I don't know
if it is expensive yes luxury okay okay
that was a the okay she does when she
doesn't really know what she wants to
eat you up for lunch oh that's good
that's a good sound
it goes with no no it looks I remember
it very vividly animals colliding
there's a line in there shopping for her
it's like shopping for your principle
I'm ready you're ready yeah okay oh
right like the fairy godmothers are
ready
I love y'all and I love that you guys
got me something that is comfortable but
I don't have these are also pieces
they're like you could wear to the
holiday party Boston I can see you
wearing this yes
honestly like this better than my outfit
today so I might just wear it today
[Music]
friends who dress each other
right I didn't have
[Music]